good afternoon
welcome to the consulate of mexico
first of all i would like to thank mayor
goodman for coming today
and for her support to make possible
this kobe 19 vaccine clinic
without you and your staff we would not
be here serving the mexican and the
hispanic
community i would also like to
acknowledge the presence
and constant support of councilwoman
olivia diaz
you are a true friend and an ally of the
consulate thanks for everything
luisa our health partner and a true
champion
of our community is here representing
rich
and making sure this clinic runs
smoothly
last but not least i must say that i'm
very
lucky to have the best staff their
unwavering commitment to the mexican
community
is really amazing
we are about to finish
a very successful copy 19 vaccine clinic
250 people were able to get
mostly seniors of the age of 65 and over
in a month they will be here again for
their second dose
and i look forward to seeing them again
because this is all for them this is all
for you
and remember keep the prevention and
take the vaccine
when it's your turn the vaccine is free
of cost
no immigration questions are asked the
vaccination
has nothing to do with immigration
control
and now without further ado i would like
to introduce to you
major goodman
pardon me for taking this off but i
think the message is so
clear and consult general this is so
exciting for the people of our community
our entire city
our latino our spanish-speaking families
are that have been for many years the
fastest growing population
that we have in southern nevada and the
most significant
and the most challenged as far as
jobs and keeping income and keeping
their families together
this particular opportunity and so
wonderful to know
this clinic is open that reach has made
it possible
here at the the council because
with this opportunity there is
the assurance is told to us by health
departments across the country
and in other areas outside
of our united states that are finding
these vaccines
really preventative and recently having
read
about the success in israel for those
over 65 and soon to be
others it is absolutely important that
we all get the vaccine
i come from a family of physicians i
have a physician
son here who might trust
and as the vaccines were being prepared
i asked an assurance from
him here what do you think about the
vaccine
and he was extremely skeptical about it
six months ago
but as time has passed and the data has
come in
from around the country moderna
and the pfizer vaccine really
are a must for each one of us to help
this community and
around the country wherever we travel
wherever we go
and our own families stay healthy
and keep this virus at bay
it will help with the other strains of
the virus
but i can assure you being one who is
well over
70 the first vaccine all i had was
discomfort
at the site of the shot
and on the second one to be perfectly
honest with you
i thought they gave me either
nothing or they gave me an energy pill
i have never felt better in my life
and stronger and know that all of us
must communicate
one to another to get the vaccine when
opportunity permits it to be given to
you
and each one of us should get a friend
to sign up
and call the council and get registered
to take the vaccine
it's a wonderful and important
opportunity and you need to do it for
your families for yourself
and for the whole community so consulate
general thank you very much for
including
me today on behalf of the city along
with councilwoman diaz who's
obviously extremely devoted to the
community here this is in her ward
her ward has more going on in it than
any other ward i think in the entire
state and she is so
lucky but it's because of the people the
culture the language the children
so much and the city of las vegas and
carolyn
levering who is the head of our
emergency management
and all our fire and rescue and everyone
else
who is participating in this wonderful
reach program
and i just wish you constant success
and know that we must all be able to say
one day
soon i have had my vaccines
so what a beautiful day we've created
just for us
where else in the country is at 72
degrees
and no rain no snow and aren't we lucky
so stay with it and carolyn levering i
see would you raise your hand
over there who has been orchestrating
this for the city since the beginning
our isoq everything that's been involved
with helping to fight this
virus so thank you very much and i give
this back to you
thank you
thank you very much mayor goodman for
your kind words and now
i present to you councilwoman olivia
[Applause]
diaz
good afternoon everyone thank you
honorable consul julianas cutie
rodriguez for the invitation to be here
today thank you mayor for
those words and encouraging our
community
to get vaccinated um and thank you
luis for leading the charge with reach
and this partnership
and making sure that we brought the
vaccines to our people
i've been talking about the impacts in
the
community the kova 19 impacts in our
latino community now for months
we know that the latino community has
been disproportionately
impacted compared to other
communities why because a lot of our
people
are hardworking people who continue to
go every day
show up for their jobs and they're on
the front lines and they're making sure
that we have food in our grocery stores
they're making sure that we have food to
serve in our restaurants
and they're part of our um working class
making sure that our casinos
are operating and are open continue to
run smoothly
so with that comes exposure and with
that exposure comes the
increased risk to come down with cover
19.
so yes the vaccination is a light at the
end of this
tunnel for the 2020 pandemic that began
almost a year ago but we cannot let our
guard down
we need to continue the course continue
to mask up when we're out in public
we need to make sure that we continue to
get tested
if you feel symptoms of a
flu or the symptoms that we've been
talking about for covet
we need to make sure that we still take
um the opportunity
to get tested for free and i think a lot
of people still don't know about
getting tested through cashmen center
which is so important
also getting and tested and knowing our
numbers are coming down
is going to be a positive site with the
number of vaccinations going up
why because our kids are going to be
able to partake in their everyday
schooling activities that's what i'm
hoping for as a mom of a fourth grader
that my son can get back to his normal
life
that people continue to be able to be
called back to their work
because they're still being they're
still waiting for that call from their
employer to say we're ready for you
and with that comes prosperity so all of
us want
our economy to reopen all of us want our
schools to reopen
but we have to do our part and our part
is
getting vaccinated when it's our turn
being patient
i know that it's been a struggle to try
to get our 70 plus year olds our 65
five plus year olds scheduled for an
appointment but we must stay the course
and we need to make sure they follow up
with their second dose this is why i
love
this setup and this partnership with the
mexican consulate and with reach
people it takes the guessing out of
getting the vaccination
they can come here get their first dose
they leave here knowing they're gonna
get their second dose
here and they don't have to worry about
where am i going to chase down my second
dose so
again this is very very powerful
to to be here today and i think that we
need to continue this kind of work
we want to bring this site to the
community and make it as easy as
possible for them to navigate
[Music]
hispanic videos
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
thanks very much councilwoman olivia
diaz for your message and
your kind words and and the call to get
the vaccine
and now i present to you luis aceves he
runs our bentania salute our health
resource center with
reach
good afternoon everyone buenas tardes
welcome
consul julian thank you so much for your
support it's an honor to collaborate
with you consul julianis
so mayor goodman um
rich has you in our hearts
we really appreciate your support
organization
i don't have words for all the support
that you gave us
i remember that time that i told you
please don't forget us and you never did
it
because you are looking
for the wellness for your people and for
everyone
we are proud that a latin american
a hispanic woman like you are
representing us
and is really an honor emperor
first i would like to say thank you
for the trust from our hispanic
community in our organization
since the beginning of the pandemic we
have been attending a lot of people
at this point reach through all their
programs
we have attended one hundred and twenty
thousand
hispanic individuals in the state of
nevada
has the momentum of the principio de la
pandemia
reached a travestos
this is the beginning we have a light
of hope right now but this is not the
end
we have a lot of work to do
and we need to do it together for them
for our people we are a puzzle
and each piece it's so important to
complete it
we will keep working we're going to
continue our work educating educating
our people
about what is the copy prevention
testing
the covenanting vaccine we need your
support
we need to support each other
there's a lot of people afraid about to
get the cabin 19 vaccine
there's a lot of people that they just
have been waiting for us
to have a vaccination date
to come to get it
done
we need your support we need to keep
working out
necessary
to all the people that trust in
our organization inventania de salud
that we're able to attend everyone
it doesn't matter where they're from we
receive everyone
salute
this is the way that mexico opened their
arms
to get help to to all the people to
everyone it is
for all of you all the media
honestly guys you here we did hard work
thank you so much for
supporting us spreading all these
messages
and today i would like to say a special
thank you for
all our volunteers all the people
the fire and rescue people the city of
las vegas people
the mexican consulate people all the
volunteers
since yesterday we did not stop
thank you so much without you
this is not going to be possible
to las vegas
today yes we provide the first dose
but today reach one
wants to touch your hearts
reach change lives with the support of
the
mexican consulate and the city of las
vegas
that is our main goal to see for our
community
to look for the wellness of our people
our main goal is to change their lives
[Applause]
thank you luis for your very warm
message
from the heart truly sincere
um we have some time to take questions
so if you have
a victor the microphone if you have a
question feel free to do it
right now or
if not yeah here
i
the hispanic am is one of the highest
ethnicities who is rate of government
how important is for you
this effort of making possible that many
spanish people
some of them
without equivocation the latino
community has been the backbone of the
growth of this entire
industry our hospitality industry
and our entire lifeblood
and so it is critical that as we begin
to open back up
our city everybody's healthy and that
doesn't just mean
elderly like myself it means next
generation
and in time we will have vaccination i
am sure
for the entire community we are part of
a greater
country and here and what we do is an
example
in las vegas there were one people who
are one family
and each one of us needs to make sure
that we
represent all of us together as we move
forward
so having our base of the hospitality
industry which is largely the latino
population
it is critical that we are all telling
each other
get the vaccine so you can be healthy as
we return to business
i love your question
my question is for um with channel
league
and we want to talk more about obviously
the effort
of kind of breaking out those
misconceptions within our latino
community
just today i became aware of how
still they were nervous and a little bit
scared to take the step
when they came out it was like they
definitely felt new they felt like they
could breathe again
some relief but once again what are we
going to do
to continue to push out this this effort
to break these uh you could say these
myths
that we're hearing out there from others
in our community
and maybe are making um some of our
community members very hesitant when
they're coming to take this step
well i think that today is the first
great step
to show that members from our community
receive the vaccination
nothing happened to them if anything now
they are going to be
more protected against covet 19. and
just because you've already gotten coven
19 i think
that a lot of people in our community
think that i already had it so i don't
necessarily need the vaccination and
that's
one of the myths that we need to really
address
that you have immunity but only for a
certain window of time
and then you are just as everybody else
likely to
have it a second time if we don't take
matters into our own hands to
to remain protected but we need to just
ensure that we're
conveying this information i know that
this past
weekend i received a text message from a
friend
his uh he had been advocating the
vaccination to his
elderly mom and he then
sent me thank you and i said why are you
thanking me and he said
because my mom just relayed to me over
lunch that
she had received a phone call urging
folks in
in your community to get the vaccination
because we had a previous clinic at
chuck minker
and we were making these phone calls and
we were urging folks to
know that these vaccinations were there
that they were accessible to the
community
and she heard our call and she made that
step to get the appointment
scheduled and she went and she got her
vaccination so as you can see
all of us play a role our children
advising their parents to get it but
also it's up to us public electeds also
sharing in the message that we need to
ensure that everyone
receives this vaccination that we don't
need to be scared or afraid
or take certain things that are posted
on social media for truth
but we really need to just continue to
show
through real life experiences like our
gomadres
our padrenos just different
people in different walks of life that
they're starting to get it and that
nothing is happening to them i think
will hopefully help us
make better speed and progress and in
helping our community understand that
this is a positive not a
relying negative on pastors to bring up
this message
how are we communicating with our
religious leaders
as soon as i know about a vaccination
clinic coming in close proximity to my
award i do reach out to those faith
leaders
we have so many from so many churches
so we try to make sure that they know
where the vaccination clinic is
so that they can also help us spread the
word because i think faith-based leaders
are
a play a very important role i know that
catholic
priests have been sharing their
pictures on their social media platforms
showing that they're getting vaccinated
that it's something safe to do and i'm
sure other faith leaders are doing the
same
and it does take the whole village to
raise up our voices and say this is
something we need to do
thank you